So, what is the point of sex?
I'm sure that some, if not all of you have
some ideas.
Maybe you’re thinking up a number of original, ingenious witticisms to answer my question with.
And why not?
In the millennia upon millennia of human sexuality,
the act itself has become no less fascinating
or complicated or fraught.
It has shaped our societies and informed our
art.
And yes, it can also be absurd and it can
make you laugh.
We made a whole episode about tardigrade sex
and there were a non-zero number of puns.
While not all sex is reproductive, today,
we’re going to focus on sexual reproduction.
What's important to remember in that context
is that sexual reproduction is not just some
mechanical process between individuals, it
is also cellular.
And while that can get lost in the mating
habits of metazoans, protozoans--or single-celled
eukaryotes--contain many of the keys to understanding
how sexual reproduction came to be.
Cuz it’s important to remember that sex
was an evolutionary innovation, a thing that at
one point, did not happen and then began to happen, and the advantages of that caused
sexual reproduction to be carried over throughout
the eons up until today.
But the evolutionary history of sexual reproduction
is complicated and it is mysterious.
And for an illustration of why that is the
case, we're going to turn to amoebas, those
seemingly simple and sexless eukaryotic blobs.
Because, it turns out that amoebas aren't
actually that simple.
Or even that sexless.
Amoebas are single-celled eukaryotes, united
by the use of pseudopodia (or "false feet")
that they use to move around and eat.
They're distributed around various eukaryotic
lineages, and we've talked about just how
tangled the taxonomic classification of amoebas
has become in a previous episode.
And for a large part of our scientific understanding
and our popular imagination, amoebas have
been decidedly asexual.
In 1932, The New Yorker published a poem called
"Ode to the Amoeba" composed by Arthur Guiterman,
a writer known for his humor.
In the poem, he writes:
Now, there are a lot of scientific details
in there that we could nitpick.
But Guiterman's poem helpfully and delightfully
lays out what has long been the pervading
image of amoebas: an ancient being that has
sustained its own individual identity by dividing
into clonal daughter cells.
Those daughter cells continue the process,
propagating into other identical amoebas or
serving as the evolutionary basis for other
species.
That image of the amoeba as primitive organism
is itself linked to what seems like an equally
primitive process: asexual reproduction.
After all, if the existential goal of any
organism is to propagate their genetic information,
then division seems simple.
It's fast, convenient, and your new clones
should contain 100% of your genome.
But there's a pretty big evolutionary limitation.
With more and more divisions, an asexual organism
will start to rack up harmful mutations that
will eventually kill off the species, this
process has a name.
It’s called Muller's ratchet and one way
to avoid this outcome is to take in foreign
DNA, a strategy that bacteria and archaea
pursue in their own recombination processes.
Eukaryotes, as we'll talk about, have sex.
Muller's ratchet poses a conundrum for our
understanding of amoebas.
If the theory holds, then any asexual lineage
of organisms shouldn't last very long.
So how do we square that with the image of
amoebas as an ancient line of organisms?
The answer is simple: we weren’t wrong about
Muller’s ratchet.
We were wrong about amoebas.
Let's start by defining sexual reproduction
at the cellular level, turning to a 2011 paper
with the wonderful title:
In this work, the authors define sex as "the
presence of a meiotic reduction of the genome
complement followed eventually by karyogamy."
That is, ya know, for us, not the set of words
that we might use to describe sex.
What it means is that sexual reproduction
involves two key processes: meiosis and nuclear fusion.
In meiosis, a cell divides, distributing its
genetic material between its progeny cells
and reducing the number of chromosome sets
each cell contains.
After those progeny cells find their mate,
the next step is karyogamy.
In this process, the cells fuse all the way
down to their nucleus, thus increasing the
number of chromosome sets and providing the
basis for a whole new member of the family.
In plants and animals, that new cell will
then divide and divide and develop into a
multicellular organism.
But in protozoans, that new cell is the organism.
Like the recombination methods employed by
bacteria, sexual reproduction provides a mechanism
for genetic variability, avoiding Muller's
ratchet.
But think of how complicated it must have
been to evolve this process, which is really
the culmination of several processes.
That altering of the number of chromosomes,
the meiosis, the nuclear fusion--not to mention
the identification of which organism to mate
with.
Meiosis itself is so complex that it is hypothesized
to have evolved a single time in the history
of life on earth.
Based on genetic evidence, that last eukaryotic
common ancestor--that mysterious evolutionary
predecessor to amoebas and all other eukaryotes--relied
on sexual reproduction.
So if we know that amoebas must be descended
from a sexual microbe, and that the odds are
low on asexual amoebas lasting for long, then
why has this image of the asexual amoeba persisted
for so long?
This misunderstanding is a product of our
own observational challenges when it comes
to microbes.
The fact is that the gold standard in confirming
sex is the ability to actually catch the organisms
in the act.
But that poses some clear problems with amoebas
and some other microbes.
First, and most obvious: they are tiny.
They can also be difficult to cultivate in
lab conditions, particularly in circumstances
that might lead to sex.
The slime mold Dictyostelium, for example,
was thought to be asexual until the 1970s,
when the scientists realized their samples
were just waiting for the right mate to show up.
Now, aside from direct observation, we now
have developed genetic methods to determine
whether an organism might engage in sexual
reproduction.
This was the case for Cochliopodium, an amoeba
that was long considered parasexual because
it followed some of the steps required for
sexual reproduction, but it had never been
observed going through meiosis.
Instead, in cochliopodium, multiple cells
fuse together to make a big cell with several
polyploid nuclei.
This mass then breaks up to create cells with
only one nuclei.
So just imagine six people fused together
into a ball of goo and then once again break
apart into six more individual people, now
all the children of those original six.
It’s a little more complicated than the
way we do it, but I’m not here to judge.
But in studying Cochliopodium further, researchers
found that they do have meiosis genes, meaning
they probably do reproduce sexually, we’ve
just never been able to see it yet.
Scientists have also found extensive genetic
evidence of sex in the Amoebozoa group of
amoebas, further challenging the assumption
that amoebas are asexual.
And this introduces a strange challenge.
We can't assume that just because we haven't
observed any particular species having sex
that it must therefore be strictly asexual
because that’s clearly not the case.
But, at the same time, we cannot assume that
all eukaryotic life engages in sexual reproduction
because to do so would mean blinding ourselves
to other evolutionary innovations to avoid
Muller's ratchet.
If there are strictly asexual amoebas, then
that's a trait they evolved further away from
their ancestors, perhaps finding an alternative
to sex that can negate some of its downsides,
like needing to find a good mate or risking
the transmission of disease.
And they wouldn't be alone.
Bdelloid rotifers are multicellular, and also
asexual.
Instead of relying on sexual reproduction
for recombination, they can acquire foreign
DNA during their resting anhydrobiosis state,
which is wild!
Some scientists have hypothesized that asexual
amoeba might have their own strategies, like
relying on having many many chromosomes to
reduce the harm of any mutation.
So what’s the point of sex?
Well, if we look at amoeba, it seems to be
both simple and unclear.
Sex is a way to create genetic variability,
but it is not the only option.
Amoebas employ a wide range of sexual and
asexual life cycles, some of which we've been
able to observe and understand.
Some of which we have not.
Arthur Guiterman wrote another poem, called
appropriately enough "Sex."
It begins:
We appreciate that Guiterman was seemingly
as preoccupied with the reproductive habits
of amoebas as we are.
Of course, now we know that the science underlying
this stanza might not be quite correct, that
amoebas were not the beginners of sex but
rather the product of it.
Just like sex itself is not just a driver
of evolution, but a result of it as well.
And that the loss of sex might also be an
evolutionary strategy.
If anything, looking at sex through this lens
seems like a reminder that the amoebas at
the start--the ones we might desognate "primitive"--are
often much more complex than we think.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
If you’re glad that there’s a channel
on youtube that is able to dive into the weird
mating habits of amoeba, well the people on
screen the folks you want to thank for that.
They are our patrons on Patreon.
And if you want to join them, You can check
us out at patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes James Weiss, check out Jam & Germs
on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, we are
at youtube.com/microcosmos